good morning Millennials or should I say
good early afternoon we are here at the
morning toast with Justin Sylvester for
sation I love that Claudia and I have
like switched coats she's in LA right
now enjoying the Sun and I'm here
freezing weight it's like The Parent
Trap it is it's exactly you'll be back
on Friday when she's doing daily pop Oh
100% she could not go to daily pop
without me that was like part of the
restrictions right and that's very fair
I wouldn't want to like what watching
you two together is gonna be a dream for
me as a super fan of my own show and of
your show I'm kind of excited I actually
may steal her from you for a few weeks
okay I mean not okay but figured out if
you it's fine done also you're the host
of Justice tape which is the best name
ever for your show it's really fun it's
actually I feel like you get more than
this if you get the whole pot the key
right it's kind of something the first
place that people can actually come and
sit and talk out their full lives in 30
minutes at E because you know
everything's so quick evenings is so
quick daily probably so quick but this
is long-form it's like inside the
Actor's Studio
yeah but a little bit dirtier right
which which we need everyone's doing all
this like quick content they like I
always say everyone's all about like
snackable stuff yeah but I don't consume
content like that that's why I love the
toast because this is the show that I
would want to watch before she in the
morning show we wish to see in the world
before a daily pop with on 100% I like
to listen to the morning toast on the
treadmill because if I can get through
the whole thing Wow like powering
through a power walk I know I did a good
job and I can get through it because you
guys are so interesting and you guys
keep me on my toes I like take a lot of
things that you say on my trip oh my god
that's so so flattering because I take a
lot of things that you say on our show
the movements are those booty calls
coming from inside the house and if I
don't know what you're talking about I
google it have the camera man like
learned the way that your neck works and
where you're gonna look next you know
it's so funny it's like a dance it's
like a dance
we literally waltz the whole time and
they know on Fridays that I'm here for
it like I'm the shadiest person on
Fridays one because I go out on Thursday
nights and I'm hungover okay and two I
get to get drunk on Fridays on screen so
the head camera guy his name is Fred
he's a director who sits in the control
room
he the Googler thing was actually him he
kept on switching the cameras and I was
just finding where the light was oh you
can see when the cameras are so I can
see the light from the corner of my eyes
I'm paying attention that is so funny
literally just a li hoop did and I
dumped it well something that I've
picked up on on your show is here we you
know we're big blind items people and I
feel like sometimes you allude to rumors
or perhaps blind gossip but you
obviously can't say it for legal reasons
and just you know a million other
reasons is that hard for you sometimes
to like be talking about I don't know
Selena Gomez when you've just heard a
million other things that aren't the
story that you're reporting on the
problem is in it and it's funny because
not that it's Selena Gomez specific I
have friends in everyone's camp right
and I have friends who work for
celebrities at stylist hairstylist you
know have agents publicist and you just
hear things throughout the industry if
you hang out in the nightclubs if you go
to the restaurants and you hear the
little bits and pieces here and there as
a friend I would never spill your tea
I'm gonna lose to it and tell you and
tell you to google it but I won't
flat-out say it so I have to kind of
sort of find the balance of what I can
and can't say and sometimes that gets
hard but I've never gotten in trouble
yet that's good cuz I was wondering you
are the lady center and a lot of the
ladies that you sit on like are people
that you talk about on your show
whether it's Kyle Richards or Chris so
how do you navigate like your own
friendships and like knowing more then
the then your audience might know I'm
not spilling too much tea but like still
keeping it interesting because people do
know that you have these relationships
for sure I think we're Kyle what you see
is what you get
she gives her whole life on camera and
she's an open book she doesn't have
anything to hide she's not trying to
hide anything she'll give you the good
bad and ugly so when I talk about Kyle
it's it's in a friendly way and it's
just matter of fact and the things that
I probably talk about you're probably
gonna see on the shorter answer let's uh
play you know the woman has no filter
but people know it's in good fun you
know I'm never gonna blast anyone I'm
gonna keep I try to humanize the
celebrities what I really try to do and
I think that people don't do that and
especially you know everyone loves to
like come in with their pitchforks and
have the same opinions on something it's
like yeah maybe someone did [ __ ] up but
like they're still a human being Jordan
woods for sure
for Jordan woods I've said this a
hundred times I was 21 at some point I
also suffer from jung-ho mine I could
not see past the D it's a clinical
problem I had chronic jung-ho mine from
the age of 19 to 24 and we've all made
those mistakes in our lives it's just
funny when you know something like this
happens to celebrity people forget that
they were you know thoughts at one point
right you know what I mean
but on the other hand I don't know what
I would do if my friend hooked up with
my baby daddy and for me and I told this
to my friend JD who's sitting over here
if this happened to us and you were
somewhere with my baby daddy the only
thing I would want is a text being like
girl ended I bet you baby daddy's house
should I stay and I'd be like stay get
all the details send him back in real
time don't kiss him but again I feel bad
for Jordan Woods for what she's going
through
we have all been there maybe not to this
degree no but we've all been there right
because we're human and we [ __ ] up we
make mistakes so what I try to do is if
it's not you you know your sister there
was a cousin or a friend who was in the
same situation right yes but then also
like similarly the College Admission
scandal I'm so man I was watching you
guys on daily pop and you guys were the
only people who were really like saying
you know what parents will do whatever
it takes for their kids like let's cut
these people a little bit of a break you
and Morgan we're looking through the
list and pointing out names so clearly
people that's crazy because aside from
Felicity have it in Lorri Lockland these
people are not really public figures
they're just you know like rich people
big money right big money and you could
see what they donate it to the college a
magnet
I would Andy King slash fire festivals
some [ __ ] for $500,000 if you handed me
five hundred thousand I'm gonna suck
some D for your kid to get the cops
right like I'm gonna figure it out for
you five hundred thousand dollars great
and also that's really not even that
much compared to what other people know
up to six million but it's crazy because
everyone's like oh on the college level
this is a disgrace but people have been
doing this for their kids to get into
elementary school and daycares around
Los Angeles forever and in New York yes
it's just how it's done and I guess what
people fail to realize it's like yes
this was taken to a criminal level the
line is so blurry as to what's legal
like dr. Dre can donate seventy million
dollars in a building and a whole
program and his daughter got in off all
on her own right the $500,000 250 a head
yes and that's where we're gonna cross
that's for Tremont job line but my
problem is listen I was so excited that
you know not that I'm like I think like
this but there were no black parents in
the college you know scam situation and
then dr. Dre had to bring his ass in to
the pole bragging on Instagram he still
did it legally yeah yeah but I just
wonder like dr. Dre completely forgot
about that 70 million did you make that
much money off of beads that you forgot
that you handed us see 70 million right
that there's a school named after you
forgot completely forgot do you think he
forgot I think he did I think you forgot
it was 2013 yenar
Jimmy was like we're gonna do this for
us see I think he completely forgot
about it didn't realize that his
daughter got and again if I don't need
to build into a school you best believe
I don't care if my grandson has a 2.0
and barely went to school is last year
he might have been in jail for his last
semester of high school his ass is going
to that College totally but I guess what
makes it legal is technically they don't
have to let him in like he could not get
and it said assurance of like you know
it's still a gamble when you donate the
library 100% still again just crazy yeah
which is very crazy did you know anybody
that's involved in no I did not other
than the big stars Felicity and Lori and
Olivia Jayden it's really sad for the
girls it's really sad however it came
out this morning that apparently they're
still enrolled at USC according to the
college I just saw that in peach six I
think they're gonna be still enrolled
for a minute I think they should stay
actually they're they're kind of far
from graduation but like and then it's
really all for nothing kids are brutal
those kids are brutal and you have to
have a really thick skin I don't know
that they have that I don't know that
they've ever been required to develop it
in their lives and you also have to
really
want to go to school like I do for her
right you didn't mean like I think for
her I think she was very proud that she
got into USC I think it was a great
experience for her and I understand
where she's coming from I didn't want to
go to college my freshman year my
parents had to like push me into it but
once I got there and once it was almost
over I enjoyed my experience where'd you
go
I would tell us you oh and it was
awesome it was phenomenal I mean I
parted my ass off and I don't know how I
got out of my freshman year at college
but we did it but that's like part of
the experience is going for it didn't
age well and I just feel like people are
coming down on her and if my parents at
17 were like stand in front of this
Christmas tree with this Rowan thing in
your hand I would've did it yeah and I
wouldn't have thought twice about it
because I would have imagined that my
parents wouldn't put me in that position
so a lot of people are blaming her and
saying cancel Olivia Jade I don't think
it's right I don't think I'm gonna
cancel her ever I'm not gonna cancel her
and have to be honest I was never so a
big fan of hers Claudia Margo loved her
videos and my sisters and actually
started watching your videos cuz I was
like oh she made all these vlogs in
college like got me watch and now I'm a
huge fan of hers I feel like this
happens a lot where people like you know
they become part of a big conversation
people who don't know them people who
know them already like are talking man
and they actually wind up getting a lot
of new fans because they have all this
exposure 100% do you mean when Jade Paul
went through that whole thing where he
took the video in the suicide forest
somewhere in a Asian country and then
everyone was like cancel Jade Paul this
man came back the next year and made 2
million more than he made the last year
and they said he made like fourteen
point eight million dollars that year
that's crazy but everyone was like can
you name but you can't and then I talked
to Claudia about this on my show if I
were to pay for you know things my
parents did in their past or said I
wouldn't have a show today hey yeah like
people would have cancer my ass we can't
keep on blaming other people for what
their parents have done right and we
can't just keep canceling people like
everyone who's there like rah rah let's
cancel like you're not perfect either
yeah you know and it's so I just
everyone's always just a little too
excited when someone's going down and
that makes me less excited about sure
but that's what celebrity is all about
if you think about why people are so
obsessed with celebrities they love the
rise
but they love the fall even more because
we love a comeback yeah we secretly
that's why the Lindsay Lohan has gotten
67.5 chances in her life yes because we
love a comeback I don't know I think
once you [ __ ] over over I think you're
kind of sort of done yeah yeah like
you're kind of you can't even get Oprah
like you know right so I think where
Michael Jackson is struggling saying
yeah once Oprah came out that was it
mm-hmm I actually stopped to watch that
second half but last night I was
watching the Sarah knows documentary I
was watching your episode II knew I
started talking about it and literally
immediately I put it on I was like this
seems interesting I don't want to spoil
by the conversation and then I came back
to daily pop it was so crazy why people
are going crazy right now I didn't even
know this was ever a thing I didn't know
this woman like I didn't recognize her
but she was everywhere she was
everywhere and by the way I don't know
who's Dumber her for you know thinking
she can get away with this which she got
away with it for a very long time are
her investors who gave her hundreds of
millions of dollars without ever being
like without checking a receipt right if
I'm giving you $10 honey I want to see
the itemized situation you got I mean
like a thousand you're gonna call me in
real time while you're buying the
products hundreds of millions of dollars
on research that no one saw one paper
for that is so scary and I now I've been
watching American greed which like
chronicles these small-time Ponzi
schemes it's the best show and all I
keep thinking about now I was like what
is the next big fraud like there are
spreads happening all the time everyone
is such a [ __ ] cake especially in
this day and age where it's so easy to
be and everyone was just instant success
mm-hmm and if it doesn't happen they're
gonna pretend that it did I'm just I'm
still reeling over the fire first of all
I know and I was supposed to go really
Dorothy Wang she's gonna kill me for
telling the story Dorothy Wang
literally called me one day and she was
like do you want to go to fire festival
and I'm like what are you talking about
she's like it's just new festival it's
gonna be the bomb ja Rule invited me
it's gonna be fun we can fly down I'm
gonna have hair and makeup but the one
thing I love about Dorothy waiting is
for me I was like yes let's go I'm in
because any adventure with her I've
known her for eight years of
life any adventure of hers is gonna be
fun but the thing that I love about
Dorothea Lange is she's one of the
smartest women I know and nothing gets
past her so she was like you know what
something sounds a little fishy so we
gonna at the first we can happen and
then i'ma tell him we gonna go to the
second weekend and I was like I can go
any weekend first we can find she's like
nope nope nope
trust me we're gonna wait when we saw
the coverage of what looked like
Fallujah in the Bahamas she was like
this is what this is why I wait this is
why I wait Wow good for her do you know
what else is so crazy she came on our
show in August of last year so 2017 and
we were talking afterwards and she was
like I think Kylie Jenner is pregnant
and we were like that's how I thought
that really and I like really couldn't
believe I was like she poses an
interesting theory a girl who was taking
body selfies all the time is now nowhere
to be found I was like but that's so
crazy she is an investigator she Nancy
Drew that says she Nancy Drew adventure
that's how you found out so I figured it
out because she like posed it but with
Dorothy leg the truth always comes out
and she doesn't forget anything so if
you're coming up with a conspiracy
theory let's say in August when it comes
true in February you're gonna get a
receipt from the screenshot that she had
saved and filed away you know nothing
gets past her what she says
I think something's going on you better
believe this woman has investigated it
that's amazing she needs to work for
American greed and sniff out the next
fraud this [ __ ] should be the head of
the FBI yeah like literally should be
the head of FBI so you were a producer
on richkids I was a producer on richkids
so I started out I worked for Kyle
Richards for five seasons and then I
went in for this
there was a Bravo show coming out and
this guy Dorado fear was actually
casting it and I was not good for it I
was like this is not me and he was like
you know I'm looking for this and this
and rich kids I'm like listen I like you
have got to meet Dorothy Wang she is
amazing Morgan Stewart Johnny
gibberellic these people are stars and
they're on richkids Instagram
you would love their friend group it's
gonna be amazing
I called Dorothy I was like listen you
have to go meet with the Rhonda Rama's a
I don't know I'm doing this thing for
Bravo I'm like no no no I'm telling you
right now these kids are gonna be stars
I don't know if you know how reality TV
works but it takes years for sure to get
on air this show was shot and premiered
six months after that first meeting Wow
that's how instant it was I love that
show so then you worked on the show so I
let them go for two seasons because
working with your friends can get a
little icky it's a little much
I let them work go for two seasons I
needed a job so I went on I produced a
show for two seasons and then when the
spin-off EJ and why see happen I
basically hi bawled them and I was fine
not coming to New York but they were
like great we'll take you with us and I
moved to New York to do ejm I see what
do you do Johnson oh and that's how you
were here for we lived in the same
building I mean you know I think I lived
there must been at the same the same
time that's amazing no it was amazing so
I did that forever and then on my flight
home from living in New York I thought
to myself because Newark is weird
there's an energy here that really
pushes you to do something else like
everybody's working not everybody is a
inste model like people are actually
going somewhere in the mornings and that
energy is so infectious so when I got
back on the plane to LA I was like
listen I'm turning 30 at the time I was
turning 30 and I was like you have to
make this happen for yourself because if
it doesn't happen between now and you
turning 30 you just got to get a big-boy
job sit behind a desk and figure it out
so I had four months to figure out my
life
and I got day without Wow do you always
want to do on camera I always wanted to
do on camera but I always hid behind the
camera because I always like I never
people always get opportunities to do
things I was always very strategic that
I never took everything that came at me
yeah like I had a very clear vision of
what I wanted to do I wanted to do the
view but on eat that's all I knew from
the time I was like 20 until I was 30
like that was my vision and I took it
and I'm doing it I'm actually doing it
but I took very specific steps like
working with Kyle was amazing I did that
for
five years it killed me to leave that
job killed me but I knew if I went this
route I would meet Morgan and I would
work with EJ and then I and I did that
for two years and then led me to you
know EJ NYC which then led me to e which
didn't let me to Daly pop yes so it was
all these a very meticulous steps that's
amazing and so now from here I usually
do the interview portion like after the
news yeah you know what we'll switch it
up today so now from here like what is
the what's the dream my dream is that I
want to die on daily pob like I
literally I want to die on the morning
test for sure like I hope hospice like
takes me out like I wanna be like a
Walters like yeah where I'm like the
oldest the you know [ __ ] on the
show and I'm sitting next to like
Northwest's and like Blue Ivy who are
now 25 26 and I'm just the old like
uncle on the show their petty uncle who
says whatever you say but I really hope
that I literally stay on daily pot for
10 years and I want my dream is to have
just a sip turn into Inside the Actors
Studio where we have a once a week
conversation on air with the talent who
just wants to get real and wrong mm-hmm
and that's what I think I'm gonna do I
love that
and also I waited for you two shows in
development when I want a brother a show
about my life with Greg Berlanti
and then I have another one that's like
a scripted scripted show another
scripted show that I'm doing and you'll
be behind I'll be behind the camera okay
that's so exciting it's gonna be fine
okay cool I'm gonna ask you any more
personal questions but first we must hit
you with the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up you need
a night out of your morning toast that's
making me hungry yeah okay first story
breaking like as we sat down Jesse smell
that's criminal charges dropped in the
attack case criminal charges against
Jesse smell that had been dropped the
Empire star appeared in Chicago Court on
Tuesday morning where the charges
against him were dropped in the case
evolving his attack in late January
quote today all criminal charges against
Jesse Smollett were dropped and his
record has been wiped clean of the
filing of this tragic complaint against
him smarts attorneys Tina gladion and
Patricia brown Holmes said in a
statement Tuesday quote jesse was
attacked by two
bill he was unable to identify on
January 29th he was a victim who was
vilified in me to appear as a
perpetrator as a result of false and
inappropriate remarks made to the public
causing an inappropriate rush to
judgment Jesse and many others were hurt
by these unfair and unwarranted actions
this entire situation is a reminder that
there should never be an attempt to
prove a case in the court of public
opinion that is wrong it is very my it
is a reminder that a victim in this case
Jesse deserves dignity and respect
dismissal of charges against the victim
in this case was the only just result I
told y'all you kind of did like you've
never totally turned I never believed I
know him and I've met him a few times
we're not friends but I know I'm in
passing and I'm a good judge of
character
I don't think somebody would make that
up to that extent maybe there was a few
fudge details along the way maybe you
know we kind of lit it up a little bit
yeah but I couldn't imagine him going
that far and I said it a few times on
daily pop I said it yesterday on cheddar
TV and everyone looks at me like I'm
crazy I'm like I don't believe it
I think when you have someone like
Jesse's mullet and the Chicago PD
coming with two stories it's somewhere
in the middle yeah because you can't
trust the Chicago PD
yeah no it's it's definitely somewhere
in the middle and I don't know if we're
ever gonna find out what really happened
he'll write a book yeah but it's like
okay so if he was telling the truth okay
and this is a horrible story terrible
horrible but the problem is now is that
they're right the court of public
opinion is much stronger than the court
of law and the fact that every celebrity
jumped on this bandwagon and they were
like support for Jesse that a lot and
then two weeks later everyone deleted
their posts because they thought they
had been duped right that hurt him a lot
and I think whenever he goes in like
Empire already wrote him out the last
two episodes when this guy goes for
another job people are only gonna
remember this right well I guess now
he'll keep his job
maybe they vote him out but they can
write him back in because they can't
fire him because that would be wrongful
termination 100% but you know if the
reports are true his contract is up they
don't have to renew it and the numbers
for Empire were down on the season
premiere
but hopefully they'll go back up now
yeah because it's like people want to
watch and they want to see what happens
in if they bring him back which I feel
like they would because they weren't
they were pretty reluctant to write him
off
you know yeah but I feel like if you
listen to some of the like people on
Empire like Lee Daniels was kind of
keeping a vague which is smart right in
hindsight it's very smart smart cuz we
didn't know anything no at first he was
like I cannot believe this happened and
prayers for Jessie in my country and
then you saw him lube to this is
devastated everybody's so upset about it
but they don't know if they're upset
about him lying are this happening to
him like it was very it was good it was
slick yeah just like Diana Ross kind of
sort of did with Michael Jackson she
kept it real vague oh yes she did we
were talking about that yesterday her in
harvest rice and just I mean compared to
Barbra Jesus yeah Barbra come on yeah no
not good she I mean she backtracked and
apologize but Barbour just needs to
figure it out yeah yeah and clone her
dog again alleging anyways we'll
continue to update that on that story as
we get more details but just it keeps on
twisting and terms oh this is not the
end of it no there's gonna be more no
especially if there's a book which there
probably will be and now that that's not
a criminal case the two brothers are
able to say whatever they want right so
they can tell their side of the story
right and we don't know if they were
cursed by the Chicago PD if they were
really involved in this at all
but we're gonna find out everything I'm
telling you in the next two weeks
oh yeah GMA and did the Today Show are
gonna try to swoop these people up real
quick
speaking of The Today Show one of us
just came from Hoda and Kathie and it
was not me it was the black one he did
it he finally did it that's so exciting
Kathie Lee's final week how did it go
just so you know when they told me about
the Today Show I literally said the only
thing I've ever wanted to do in my life
is sip a glass of wine with Kathie Lee
and I didn't even pick up my glass once
today I'm so mad about it I'm so nobody
you were so busy and you know you always
could turn to they drank plenty of like
nothing to say right it was crazy
but it was amazing just to feel the
energy in there you could tell that
people are so happy to be in that space
and they're so proud of the work that
they're doing it literally felt like am
I wrong like Willy
Wonka Chocolate Factory everyone was
smiling everyone was literally smiling
in there it was a crazy thing well
that's a great segue into our next story
because Jennifer Aniston and Reese
Witherspoon teased a new Apple series
called the morning show yes Apple
finally lifted the curtains on its
much-anticipated reunion of Jennifer
Aniston Reese Witherspoon revealing the
first footage from their new TV series
Monday the friends alums appeared at
Apple's special event to introduce the
morning show a series that would examine
the people and politics of the Morning
News world
quote through the prism of those
underslept over adrenaline people in
front of them behind the camera we take
an honest look at the complex
relationships between women and men in
the workplace and we engage in the
conversation people are little too
afraid to have unless they're behind
closed doors but of course Aniston
pointed out you can't have an honest
look at complex relationships between
men and women with just women q Steve
Carell who bumbled onto stage promising
to bring the quote manliness to the show
teasing that his character was bold and
dynamic with a lot of gravitas he's a
great listener and relatable and
extremely handsome this is exciting
I am so interested by the world of
morning shows which is why we started
one did you ever see the movie Morning
Glory yes that is the reason why the
show exists because we love it and now
we have Celine Dion's
personal chef yes do you ever I wish the
drama was that big on a morning show I
know but maybe I miss it because I'm
always in my own world that daily pop
like when I get in there I go to my
meeting and then I'm literally gabbing
and talking to everyone to see what
their opinions are and how they feel
about you know you know everything
that's going on on the show today so I
never get a chance to see the the drama
however there are politics behind closed
doors yeah so I do get it but I'm
interested to see what they do and I
love that Jennifer Anderson is doing TV
again yeah do you watch friends I love
oh my god I hate friends Claudia loves
it and it's like the one thing we don't
agree on are you trying to like one
character too much is that what it is no
I just think first of all I hate a laugh
track so that just automatically bothers
me I get that
and then I'll watch an episode and I
just don't think it's funny and maybe
it's because I don't like any of the
characters so I'm not like oh oh
that's hilarious yeah did you like the
hills uh yeah okay I think maybe it's
the age group yeah like I think living
in New York with no internet and like
you know going to a coffee shop to hang
out I think you might have missed that
boat because you're so young perhaps
yeah like if you didn't start it early
you're not gonna like it now because
it's also not the kind of TV we're used
to yeah a sitcom with laugh tracks and
these old style jokes 100% yeah like I
don't want you Seinfeld either you see I
think it's that whole I know what's your
favorite show script it ooh
skirt I don't watch so much scripted um
right now dynasty oh oh you're not
watching dynasty I [ __ ] love dynasty
do you watch Nikolai Sheridan's off the
show I'm done I'm you're done
if Nicholas charity was not showing up
next season about she's not and I think
I from what I heard that she was
obviously difficult to work with this
isn't the first time that we've heard it
and they didn't want to kill off Alexis
because actually this would be a really
big spoiler and now it's oh I'll tell
you laughter yes but she's definitely
not seeing her again Nicollette Sheridan
cannot keep a job she can't keep him and
she can't give a job um I can't believe
you watch it's the most underrated show
it's amazing okay good I was like I
thought you were saying you don't watch
it yeah I love it but I love Nicollette
Sheridan I'm not gonna watch it down
that she's off of it oh I love Liz
Gillies oh and I'm loving the new
crystal I liked the old crystal too I
love the old crystal new crystal like it
has you know bigger set of balls which
is nice because old crystal is so meek
oh I can't believe you watch that show
we don't talk about care okay great oh
my god I love it so much anyways back to
morning shows uh have so is this like a
documentary-style reality show that's
what I was getting the vibe of where
they're gonna talk to existing morning
show hosts on this morning show yes it's
a scripted show just about morning shows
no tried this like there was great news
do you remember that show with Nicole
Richie was the only bright spot in it
but this was I think this is more of a
sitcom I think this is gonna be more of
a drama okay like that other show Aaron
Sorkin's yes in his room
I think that mixed with a little comedy
but anything that Reese Witherspoon
engine
Frandsen gonna sign up for with steve
carell this show is gonna be a hit
right and it's Apple's first TV show and
they're throwing money behind it honey
Chris McMillan is doing hair on a TV
show his day rate is nothing less than
$20,000 that's so exciting
okay I didn't realize it's gonna be
super that makes it all so interesting I
thought it was gonna be like talking to
the people who wake up early at 3:00
a.m. it's gonna be like the drama behind
the view which apparently there was a
lot of yes according to earth yes so
what time do you wake up for your job I
have to be at my office at 6:15 so I
roll out of bed at 5:50 and I just
literally get up and go that's nice for
you cuz I can shower there I can like
brush my teeth there I am NOT a morning
person I'm not a morning person either
I've become one because of this show but
we go live late enough that most people
don't consider at the morning no for
sure my husband is such a morning person
and he has all this energy it makes me
even angrier I hate it and I document my
mornings so like me walking into a
meeting looking like I just got dragged
behind a garbage truck is always on
there which you'll see on Friday when
Claudia comes in and hair and makeup we
have a dance party to wake up it's good
it's a fun time 6:00 a.m. is not fun
when you're a thirty year old single man
and like you want to go out oh I go out
I function still you can function
hungover like that I do my best work
hungover
honestly when Claudia is hung I can't be
I'm like a death becomes her hungover so
when Claudia said cuz if I'm hungover
there's no show but Claudia can come in
hungover and it's so funny oh my my boss
some of the the only days where he is
like man you are on fire today I'm like
boo if you're gonna breathalyze me I'd
be in jail I would literally be in jail
right now if you breathalyze me I take a
little bit of work on Fridays yeah cuz
we get lit Oh cuz you can't try cuz I
can't drive that make sense it's the
better to work every day because I don't
know how to drive you can't live in LA
your wart right your wardrobe for the
show do you wear your own clothes do
they bring in clothes like that must be
so fun it's so much fun I'm styled by
this girl named Jenny Rodriguez she's
phenomenal she has like a lot of people
in the industry car Richards she sells
me Giuliana
Rocsi Diaz and she knows my style by now
so I don't normally look at what I'm
wearing for the
I just roll in they have it steamed and
I just throw it on Wow
because she and I have worked together
for two and a half years she knows like
I want to be a little hood like Ryan
Seacrest yes a tiny baby
yeah hood Ryan Seacrest okay next in
s'more TV show news Wendy Williams
husband's alleged mistress gives birth
the alleged mistress of Wendy Williams
husband Kevin hunter has given birth to
a baby multiple sources told page six
while frail TV chat show Queen Wendy
remains in a queen sober-living house
Serena Hudson gave birth to a baby on
Monday at Philadelphia Hospital wow
they're naming names here in hospitals
where you can look up records by the way
first of all Wendy I love you why are
you in a sober house in Queens you are
rich you have coins I think that's the
point that's like Demi Lovato and she
was in a silver house when she was a
judge on x-factor mmm but not in Queens
no she was in sheshe Beverly nice that's
true that's Jim she was a Malibu honey
she was not playin around it has not
been confirmed that Wendy's husband
Kevin is the father of the child but
there is widespread speculation that he
is indeed the father one source said
quote Serena gave birth to the baby at
Hanneman University Hospital in Philly
apparently they chose this location
because they were worried that if she
gave birth in New York it would be
leaked to the press well it's too late
to a second source said this is a crazy
situation when is when he is in a
halfway house fighting for her sobriety
while her husband is at the sight of his
mistress who is giving birth to a baby
Serena went into labor on Sunday and is
believed to have given birth late on
Sunday or in the early hours of Monday
y'all somebody was really given all this
right there's a lot of details we're
gonna get the name soon it is specific
oh we're gonna get that baby's name for
sure but the rumor is that she already
has a baby with this man already oh this
is the second child allegedly that is so
crazy because as we were saying before
like imagine if wendy was reporting on
this story about another celebrity and
she would be like get out what are you
doing but I feel like Wendy Williams
knows that everyone knows his dirty
little secret and by the way Wendy
Williams may have an open relationship
with her husband that we don't know
about because I live in Los Angeles and
I'm in the gay community and a lotta gay
men have open relationships and a lot of
open relationship
aren't open to the public right so they
keep it to themselves and they leave
things on the sides and they have their
like you know they have their
understanding right and I don't know if
Wendy is one of those people because I
have heard this continuously about this
woman and her husband so I have to
believe that Wendy Williams knows about
this what is she like I know she Whitney
knows because Whitney knows everything
the problem is Wendy's not being
completely honest with her audience and
as a fan of Wendy Williams I just wish
you would be like listen we working
things out in my marriage like you know
this has come out this is you know
what's happening
we have understanding scab my business
and I'd be like great I can move on but
I felt like when Wendy went into that
sober house there was something that was
a catalyst that she wasn't sharing and
now it seems like maybe her finding out
about this love child was a catalyst for
her relaxing right and we would be
understanding of that but I think we
always talked up a lot of things like in
Hollywood you know people cheating
athletes blah blah blah that there's
this understanding that a lot of couples
must have because like they just live in
another world they're in Hollywood Oh a
lot of this is over I think that for her
to explain that to her audience they
wouldn't get that yeah but there have
been many people celebrities that have
been in open relationships and that have
talked about it openly like you can
google it there have been a lot of
people you know you can say these things
on this show yeah the way that I've been
like oh we have an open relationship but
what a lot of people don't do is a lot
of people say okay we're gonna have to
open relationship but don't embarrass me
in public don't let just come out 100
percent thought of thing that was open I
think she was literally hit off a left
field yeah you know but he embarrassed
her in public which made it even worse
there are a lot of athletes who have
girlfriends that travel with them all
across the world so their wives can
chill at home and sometimes when they
can get in touch with their husbands
they're calling the side chick being
like hey is mala there I need to talk to
him real quick there are people who
actually have that situation because
guess what if you're dating an athlete
if you're dating a rapper I would rather
know the one [ __ ] that you're sleeping
with then the 50 that I don't know about
which is so crazy to think about
but it makes sense it makes sense
because if my pap smears off guess who
I'm calling you calling the one side
[ __ ] who was supposed to be there in
Philadelphia when you can't when you
were there yeah can you imagine I could
not imagine No
so that's I I don't know that everyone
would be so understanding which is why
maybe she hasn't like shared with the
class but isn't the world progressive
wouldn't you understand if like Wendy
was like my husband and I have a mutual
relationship there is a design I can't
even go into that I was about to say you
guys know where to find nd right it's
just like there are some people that
marry you know men that aren't into
women but they're married and they have
a great relationship and it's a business
relationship and it's bumping and
grinding and killing it and and it works
for me and it works in both of them but
guess what those people each have boy
toys and girl toys on the side and no
one knows about it because they keep it
respectful right but I think that's this
is disrespectful like he's out of his
mind but he and Wendy had been together
for a long time and it seems like Wendy
is under his spell and her friends want
him to get away from her him but Wendy
can't just yet yeah
Wendy can be did you know that something
was going on when she was yeah away from
mom yes and I had heard these rumors
there was like a fetal a year ago or so
like where someone like I had a picture
of him with the girlfriend or you know
profile on her and so I was like okay
there's clearly some weirdness and
Howard Stern was calling her out and
then when she went away for a while it
was clear it wasn't it was kosher
yeah by the way if you're gonna have a
mistress and your wife is gonna be on TV
I'm speaking hypothetically this is
allegedly you don't put mail to your
mistress's house yeah don't let your
mail go there for all of you watching
why would you have mail going to this
woman's home it's only nuts it's always
the mail fraud is learning about alright
I'm like I didn't know what mail fraud
was for so long like Teresa and Joe
we're keys of it I'm like what is no
fraud like you didn't use a stamp you
know it's like everything if you ever
lie in May
you've committed male committing
male/female - that's called peaceful
mail fraud right it's all like crazy
it's all snuck it in the mailbox without
a stamp and black people were not
involved in this right and if you can't
state it enough no I said all the time
with no black people harmed in this game
tag way to our next story which is that
Yael rescinds and mission as first
student faces the consequences of the
college scandal Yale University has
rescinded the admission of a student in
connection with the far-reaching college
admissions college admissions scandal
the university confirmed Monday it is
the first known case in which a
student's involvement in the scheme has
resulted in a revoked admission dozens
of parents are accused of cheating or
paying bribes to get their children into
elite schools including Yale USC and
UCLA well I just have to say this is
great timing for this student because
the admissions process is still
happening you can get in as late as
April and you know if you get
wait-listed you'll find out this summer
maybe take a gap year this isn't the end
all and be all four you know but if that
name gets released it's going to be the
end-all be-all
right but so far so good so far so good
I would rather be this student than
Olivia Jade 100% right but by the way
I'm gonna call this right now and you
can mark my words and you better mark
this and play this when it does happen
Olivia Jade is gonna come back from this
ten times stronger than what she started
at her numbers are gonna be up her
endorsements are gonna be bomb she is
gonna come back from this I I think that
she really can come back from this I
hope she knows that like I hope she
knows that it will be okay I hope she
has it's all about like who you are what
you're made of
everyone gets knocked down it's how and
when you get back up yeah so I hope that
she has the inner strength to pull it
off because she can the problem is
though and this is not a huge problem
but it's a big problem her mother has
never been involved in a scandal before
Lori Loughlin has her large lawyer
Lachlan sari has one of the cleanest
records in Hollywood like hallmark we're
talking Aunt Becky that's why I cannot
cancel on Becky she did one thing wrong
in her life like the first thing that
she ever did wrong granted is gonna end
up at the Supreme Court but I don't
think Olivia Jada is gonna be prepared
to know that
there's the other side because their
family has never gone through something
like this right
you know I mean and for the public it's
it's so shocking that it's Aunt Becky
you know where as Lynette Scavo would do
something like Lynette Scavo would do
some [ __ ] like that right and by the way
I bet you the one thing I've said on
this show and I've said it a thousand
times is when you're in a relationship
with somebody I don't care if we've been
dating for three months three years
thirty years you better never [ __ ]
say I told you so
and I bet you William H Macy is that I
told you so right because the emails he
was on they didn't go through with it
because he was probably like this isn't
kosher this is a Goshen and I saw that
there had there's rumored that they're
having problems cuz he said I told you
so I would strangle my husband from here
like I would we're in New York right now
we would be in the Hamptons and I would
literally I would chop his dick off if
you told me I told you so it's the one
thing you do not say in a relationship
right because it's not gonna make
anything better no you wait until I'm
passed out are you in the shower to say
it or you find a roundabout way cuz the
good thing about i-told-you-so is you
then are letting the person know like
okay maybe I'm not wrong all the time so
you have to find a way to say that where
it's like not I told you so because
that's a death sentence it has to be I
don't even know how you could say it but
like I thought this might be a possible
yes yes maybe in the future we can
discuss these decisions before you make
them 100% but do you think Frank
Gallagher is gonna go in a roundabout
way Frank Gallagher's like I told you so
right like I told you not to do makeup
every morning and you know and poor her
I feel bad for her because they only be
about 15 G's like right there's this
very minimum about what happened there
wasn't photos taken
it wasn't anything that's happening like
that illegal but she had guns drawn on
her at six o'clock in the morning in her
Beverly Hills home and everyone thought
because they all live in this cul-de-sac
in bel-air so it's like her and then
next to her is Dan Bilzerian do you know
Dan Bilzerian is everyone thought the
FBI was there for dan Bilzerian
meanwhile they were there for Felicity
Huffman that's crazy is it it not wow I
didn't realize that he
lives there too he's so fine yeah I
follow him he's dirty he's attorney he's
interesting and like there's no one else
that's doing what he's doing good or bad
in your single days would you have done
it no because of like all of the girl
like there are so many girls and like
that's a lot but like if he was just a
man in a bar yeah oh you know what I
would I drink some betadine to the party
we bring some Clorox wipes I would wipe
it down real good I would take that
first layer skin off first and then I
would do it I'm telling you right now he
is fine yeah he's really cute and a man
who he's got right and he's not afraid
to like spend it you know I mean he's
fine and I'm not into that Jurassic look
what every once in a while oh I would I
would let him I'd be I'd be in the harem
jumping off the roof not quite I'm not
that adventurous like you know I would
still be in a full body condom but I
would do it
and those girls look like they're having
fun you know it's like they want to be
no one's and making them be there those
[ __ ] they get jobs everybody there
hanging with the party animal of the
year that's would like what's his name
used to be like Leo back in the day -
like the ghost nests and like the social
media like Leo used to get down like
that but they used to party they were on
trips they were on yachts private jets
he is a good new leonardo dicaprio you
just put a little bit more money right
and it's like if you're gonna have that
much money like at least have fun with
it you know some people are so serious
and so boring 100% I'm so like I'd like
the way that he's spending his money but
I want to know like what like thought
lands like mrs. Dan Bilzerian yeah it's
all about timing he wakes up one day and
he's ready to be done and it's the first
girl he seen Trisha you ready we're
gonna do this Trisha we're going to
Vegas gonna get a new set of tits and
we're gonna give every today you know
it's gonna be like that quick situation
but the
being like the happiest couple on the
block right then it's just like life is
about timing so I couldn't even give
those girls any advice for how to be the
one other then it's a numbers game
uh-huh
90% of life he's just showing up or
whatever at Andy Warhol's head right and
by the way if your weight is the best
thing that you can do is figure out what
time dance alarms going off and put
yours 20 minutes before get up put some
makeup on your face brush your teeth
always look like fresh when he wakes up
and just yawn right next to him you
shouldn't look fresh yeah and then like
that day that he does wake up it wakes
up mentally you're ready you're you're
the one wood white nail polish on ready
for the ring to go on Oh white nail
polish I need to pay me always I'm like
so embarrassed with my hands right now
fifth and final story speaking of being
wiped up the Joe Broz are in Miami with
the Jay sisters as they call themselves
and they're having a blast and I'm
having FOMO and for so long I couldn't
make sense of this whole family and we
were so skeptical of Nick and Priyanka
like we were like they could be married
50 years why pick up Ben's grandchildren
and we still won't believe it but I'm a
believer now I was the same way until I
met him okay like I was like I can't see
them together it doesn't make sense but
he is so suave out of the the joan i
nuclei he is the suave as one yes so
swaggy he's so suave and she's so
beautiful and exotic I feel like they're
a match made in heaven
however I don't know how bad maybe Bob
came to me right and it's like was it
sponsored no no it wasn't sponsored but
I might listen thank you get a number
one hit you don't buy me a Maybach I buy
you Amina right like it was like the
weirdest AG thing after you just had
this like 30 million dollars set of 18
weddings like what's happening here
where the funds coming from where I
needed inside the house 100% like
somebody's doing some shady ass [ __ ]
right but now they're back on top of
their game on top of the boat in Miami
dancing along to Kacey Musgraves golden
hour and they're having a blast and I
love the surface sophie turner up at all
like she can party I just feel bad for
sophie Turner you do and I say this
because I went through something similar
like my stepsister had one of the nicest
weddings in the world
and I just could never top it so in
order to live I have to just get married
at a courthouse and like a leisure suit
and have like pancakes after you know
how do you top that wedding but I feel
like for most people that's not an
attractive wedding like that is so big
and so extra and like I feel like to her
it's like that's not a competition
because she was never striving for that
wedding like they're gonna get married
and probably England or wherever she's
from and it's gonna be countryside it's
gonna be a whole different vibe that you
can't even compare the two like this is
royal wedding and this is like barnyard
land right right those are great vibes
you just have to pick your lane and then
go all the way mm-hmm so I feel like
she's not even competing with them right
because she's gonna have like a totally
different type of wedding she'll
probably it'll be like a frat party
house party like they'll be like yes
Nick and Priyanka coast was beautiful
and elegant but this was fun yes yes yes
I just have to imagine I don't know it's
weird but I think they work I think
they'll work out I think yeah I mean
obviously Kevin and Danielle are the
template for a great uni relationship
Kevin and Danielle are a great template
except I don't know how Danielle is
gonna do with Kevin going back on the
road because she's had her husband in
her life with the two kids like she has
like had the normal family situation
when your husband decides to put his
balls back out there and to be on the
road and be in front of people it's a
little bit different you can get a
little resentful if you were at home
with two kids in New Jersey and your
man's all over the place with his
brothers not that he would do anything
wrong but I think when you're stuck at
not stuck at home but when you're at
home raising two kids and your husband
seemingly having the time of his life it
could get a little much yeah especially
if he getting used to having him around
right but now she'll just get used to
like the money from the tour I think she
cares about the money that's true but he
needs have a job like he hasn't been
working going he owns a construction
business oh yeah and you know what the
Joe Broz I feel like have been getting
residuals for a year it's like they
weren't in that loop
situation where the money was stolen
like there are paper trails and they're
going to the your money is always stolen
the money is always throwing from a fat
white guy it's always like the bald fat
guy who still is the buddy like if my
manager is like hey I'm like you look
like Lou Pearlman you gotta go yeah I
cannot do it with you I was just
watching an American greed about I think
his name was Ken Starr yes the money is
always stole it and like these are smart
people that they're stealing from it
it's like why don't they just hold on to
their own money like what the risk of
having a money manager what is the
reward it's the people come in with a
charisma in the connections and once
somebody tells you that they know
somebody else in Hollywood how it works
out is one agent will be like oh I
manage this person and that person and
then you're like oh well that person was
doing amazing let me just get in with
this with this whole group but people
don't realize that what happens is
they're being legit with the celebrity's
money that doesn't mean that they won't
doubt they'll be legit with your very
true so that's how it all happens of
course but look at Johnny Depp ya wasted
away all that money like you thought
maybe there'd be a money manager behind
him and there was right but he was
spending two million dollars a month on
Weinman that is so interesting that's
also like in Molly's game when she was
like doing her poker game and like
whoever Michael Cera was playing tell me
why it's like well Tobey Maguire's
playing so now everyone's coming to the
game that's I don't get that maybe I'm
just like not enough of the thirsty like
[ __ ] it's but it's how fashion OVA
made their business shout-out to fashion
over because the business model is
amazing they get the clothes are cute
they'll fall apart in one wash but the
clothes right but these days people only
wear something once they close it on
Instagram in there they're not gonna
wear it again they gotta go perfect you
may get a rash sorry cut that out it's a
little edgy but it's the cashmere is
cashmere but but that's what it looks
good on TV and Lowe's get an extra you
have cardi be wearing it you have Nicki
Minaj in it you have the Kardashians
wearing it and people will go for those
fast fashions and that's when people in
Hollywood do that's how this games
always happen you have the one guy the
one pagan god in your
Tobey Maguire and then you get all the
other chumps that want to be in that
whole circle it's so sad people just
want to be in the light of a celebrity
they don't care if it's legal illegal if
they're going to like you know get
colonics as long as they're next to
celebrity they'll get a colonic next
time but it's so crazy because it's also
people who are like at the top of their
business game finance sports and still
it's like Tobey Maguire Oh where's Tobey
no matter what any [ __ ] tells you they
could have all the money in the world
they could have the houses they can have
the planes they can have it all the one
thing you cannot buy in this world is
Fame you can become Noah you can have
Neriah tea you can be infamous but to be
famous you it has to be a perfect storm
you got to have the talent you got to
have the looks you got to have the quirk
and you got to be at the right place at
the right time if anyone tells you it's
hard work it really is hard work once
you get there proving that you can stay
somewhere is the hard part but getting
there and being present and like really
getting someone to notice you it's all
about who you know and it's about luck
it really is it really is I think we'll
say that 90% luck 2% Talent I'm quoting
all these people today and I don't know
who I think they're all up Woody Allen's
yeah but blaming on Woody Allen is I
know she's made over reality but that's
what it is yeah you cannot cannot by
thing at all unless you're a real
housewife and you have a [ __ ] ton of
money in a nice house and a husband
that's doing some crazy [ __ ] then you
give back right okay we're gonna talk
about how sizing before I let you go we
have some questions for you and just
want to get to know you
yes so what justice if is amazing if you
guys haven't watched it yet my favorite
and I don't know I'm tied between my
like an America Jane and that's also
just a personal struggle with I don't
know who I love me yes but I think I
love your episode with Lala because she
really went she went there she went
there like newly engaged and we don't
get to see her engaged on the show right
now so we don't know what she's like an
engaged woman she is everything and if
you like that one day bigs actually
comes out tomorrow it's one of my
favorites that I've done so far I'm so
he's not really very reserved and very
you don't know much about his personal
life but he goes there and he talks and
that's what Justin tips about it's
supposed to be a place where celebrities
feel comfortable to tell you about their
lives well how do you make celebrities
feel comfortable because it really feels
like in every interview that you do that
you're best friends with this person
whether or not you actually are
I give them wine just a little bit of
whispering angel a little Roseate goes a
long way when you talk to somebody and
you're sharing a drink with them it's a
very intimate moment and I think for
myself a lot of interviewers are afraid
to share their personal lives because
they want to be seen as a reporter for
myself I want it to be a conversation
where we can go back and forth so if I
ask you a personal question I am
prepared if you ask me the same one and
I'm prepared to open up about it it's so
important it's important because if a
celebrity says well why don't you answer
that and I'm like sure I went to a
spring break in Fort Lauderdale and I
got like you know like you gotta be I
will let you know for a lot of you who
is a dream guest for justice said Oprah
Oprah Oprah
I wouldn't ask for anything I'll just
let her talk for two hours yeah I would
just let her talk for two hours because
I feel like no matter what you Oprah
says you're gonna get the best lesson of
your life ever learned she actually saw
me happy 30th birthday the day before my
birthday it was the greatest moment of
my she's a great voice - she has an
amazing voice all I want to do is sit
and talk with her just about it all but
I want to wait until it the point where
she gets where she is like ready to let
it all out
you didn't mean like Quincy Jones last
year was like I am 77 and I'm just gonna
talk [ __ ] he's like Michael Jackson was
gonna be like yeah I'm ready for Oprah
to tell me everything yeah word on it
word vomit that's a good name for a show
Jim so did you come up with an injustice
it I came up with just anyone else could
have I came up with justice it and they
fought me tooth and nail on it what
makes sense on so many different levels
first of all Justin just the same thing
just the tip so it's like sexual
innuendo and then it's you're sipping
tea they thought me should have brought
me in
now on it I was like it's the one thing
about this show that I am not changing
yes and they're like we don't I'm like
I'm telling you John we are not changing
this show name and they tried to talk me
out of it
they were like give us two backups I'm
like just a sip 2.0 just to say 3.0 like
you better pick one it's happening thank
you better just you better get it and
they let me have just a sip and it's
been so great they I feel like when I
first got in there they were like kind
of nervous because I'm a very big
personality and the lucky part about Who
I am is when you're a black and you're
gay you can say whatever you want it's
why Wendy Williams gets to say anything
she wants on TV because she's a black
gay man in her head would you're black
gay man you've been oppressed in two
different ways so you can also talk
about the oppressed because no one will
be like well what have you been through
in your life and I'm like ma'am I got a
man from South Louisiana who may or may
not be Jewish right now like I've been
through it all yeah
so I think when I walked in there I was
kind of sort of the only one of my kind
I was a unicorn in the office and they
really let me go for it that's so nice
and so refreshing because you don't get
that in a corporate environment ever
they'd really that's how you like stripe
gold you know when you keep following
this timeline it's like you're gonna say
you have to like break the mold in order
to be interesting you have to break the
mold and I always say like whenever I
get a topic there's two things that I
like to do one I like to three things
one I make sure I humanize and make you
make a connection with the celebrity
whether it be yourself your sister your
brother you're gonna feel like you know
that person and someone in your life has
gone through the same thing because I
think it's fair for the celebrity the
second thing I like to do is I like to
TVT some things and figure out other
celebrities that a been through this or
if the celebrity him or herself has done
this in the past and I like to bring up
some old tea I like to Drudge up some
old coffee bean you know and the third
thing I like to do is I like to see
what the next step is gonna be for that
person because I know a lot of
publicists and managers watch daily Bob
and I know a lot of celebrities that
people who work with celebrities have
come back and said by the way i watch
daily pop and we literally followed your
advice to a tee oh my god like when
their clients were in a situation
because I can't come from a PR
background so the next steps I always I
say this person should do this this and
this and I had a manager be like I've
done it multiple times with two
different clients Wow
so smart learning like insider secrets
and I'm like I'm gonna Senor s invoice
next week right yeah Wow so how do you
prepare for an episode of the show you
like get the stories how much you like
to know about it versus do you guys how
do you do you plan what you're gonna say
so we normally go at 6 a.m. in the
morning 6:30 is our first meeting and
they give us an outline of the show
what's going to be on it and normally
the a and the B and the C block are the
biggest stories that are happening right
now and then the D and E and F block are
more lifestyle stuff yeah evergreen
stuff what I like to do is I like to
send stories the night before that I'm
interested in because when you're on air
talent and you feel passionate about
something the audience can feel that you
actually have an opinion and you feel
you know for that person or that story
or their topic so I like to send stories
in so most of the stories that are on
the show come from me the night before
because I look at everyone i watch
everything oh so you do watch everything
because literally part of our job is
what keeping up with everything every
show you guys have all these guests come
on do you feel compelled to watch stuff
that you wouldn't ordinarily watch like
do your homework for the show so that
you can speak to everything if someone
is taking their time out of the busy
schedule to come and promote their you
know projects on my show especially a
celebrity I owe it to them to be versed
in it you mean yeah like if you're
coming to daily popping you'd never see
an episode of it guess what you're gonna
watch an episode of daily pop I owe you
the same thing yeah cuz I never want to
celebrity a comment and feel like we
haven't you know we're not on top of our
jobs or we don't know anything so I
literally if there's a celebrity list of
people that want to come in which we get
all the time I either highlight
say today we can do this or next week we
just want them to feel like you know
like you know yeah and you should know
who has been your favorite interview so
far our Wayne Brady I've been waiting to
me for a very long time because people
get me confused at Wayne Brady and I
just think Wayne Brady's like a genius
Tracee Ellis Ross was phenomenal I
really liked águia zeliha really because
she's exactly what you think she is
oh good like she's a I thought maybe it
was an act I was like she can't be this
hood she ain't that Street she's exactly
who she thinks she is
and I'm obsessed with her after
interviewing her I think my final person
that I interviewed was Monique I thought
I was hoping you were gonna say her I
loved I didn't know all up so much of
the backstory and then I went looking
into it afterwards I thought she was so
well-spoken [ __ ] it's like everyone has
come for her [ __ ] and she does not care
and she does not care she is literally
like I don't give a flying [ __ ] can I
say that on it yes I mean frankly she's
like I don't care I'm gonna say my piece
and I'm gonna stick to my guns and I
think for me at first when I first read
about what was going on my first
instinct was like please back down like
don't ruin this for yourself like you're
taking it too far but when she explained
it to me and after seeing her over the
months I fully support her me too
I think she is gonna come back from this
she's her biggest show was bomb she's
killing it she's gonna love her mother
and I mean she has that just like
likeability so even if everything that
she did was wrong which I did now I
don't think that it was but even if that
were the case like people forgive yes
people move on but still she's not
backing down tonight I really really I
just think it's so refreshing I
appreciate it so much easier sometimes
just apologize 100 people want you to
say and then like get back into
everyone's good graces as opposed to
like going against Oprah
yeah what you don't do you know which I
don't can't Oprah stabbed me in the
middle of Times Square and it was on the
jumbotron I would still be like I ran
into the knife I didn't know I did this
to myself it's totally fine it was Gayle
that was not Oh
was game over I would never go against
him because that's you know what you
learn in your life is you don't go
against the powerhouse but if she felt
compelled that she was wrong and I don't
know what happened on the back end I
just admire her for not giving up and
for not standing down me too
speaking of just have to cover one more
thing before I let you go which is puppy
gate
not giving up and not standing down it's
what everyone's talking about a little
bit ad nauseam
I am so team Teddy I can't even tell you
and I know that you are and I know you
said something that Lisa Vanderpump on
daily pop and I've been meaning to ask
you because I I think it might pain you
to say like a kind word about her and
you said that you respect the craft
craft cease craft by the way please
elaborate
I respect the craft and like I actually
like Lisa Vanderpump I like Lisa
Vanderpump because when Kyle started
this journey it was my first day of work
her first day of shooting so if you look
back in the history of it
Kyle and Lisa are the last two remaining
housewives and I love Lisa Vanderpump
because Lisa Vanderpump is about her
business and she takes no prisoners and
I like a crafty [ __ ] yeah I like a
[ __ ] who's gonna move a chess piece to
make sure her his kids that she can you
know crown that king I don't mind that I
just get nervous when the craft gets
sloppy yeah when you get sloppy in the
craft is when you get caught cuz you get
caught up in the whole moment you know I
mean and I think for her a lot of people
are turning against her but how people
or not you know of her people are still
loving her and all everyone in teddy is
saying you know keep watching the truth
will come out and it clearly is like
there is this big riff right now between
Lisa and the rest of the group is she
gonna film the reunion is she gonna be
back next season so I have to I think
more comes up that will make people turn
against Lisa Vanderpump as someone who's
been watching forever and has seen this
craft go down over and rants and you
keep thinking this is gonna be the end
for her throw her to the wolves and she
returns leading the pack let me just
tell you something right now
you guys once you turn this podcast off
you go to Brandi Glanville magazines the
magazines the magazine you go to Brandi
Glanville's podcast there's one about
Lisa Vanderpump
keep in mind Lisa Vanderpump embrace
they were very close friends for a very
long time and then Lisa kind of threw
brandy on the bus and then Brandi
through Lisa under the bus if you go to
Brandi Glanville's podcast and listen to
this podcast
it will all be summed up for you in less
than 30 minutes okay because she recent
it's recent it happened a few weeks ago
three or four weeks ago Brandi has no
skin in the game she is out of it
situation and for the longest time she
did not like Kyle because of the things
that Lisa you know yeah kind of told her
but I think to be a housewife you have
to go in with you either have to be
super authentic as Kyle has been this
whole time or you gotta be super crafty
yeah but you've gotta be you have to be
smart about the graph because a lot of
housewives kind of break right like they
start off crafty and in the lies catch
up with this right which is kind of sort
of what you're seeing right now the
police if she keeps spinning it though
and she has an explanation for
everything except for how she knew that
Teddy knew yes that's the question she
actually can't answer and I think it's
so poetically justice filled that Teddy
is the one to call her out being the
accountability coach that she is because
when Teddy came in season one so many
people thought she was the weakest link
and be like no this girl is gonna be the
one to bring down Lisa Vanderpump Oh
100% and it's exciting but the thing
that Lisa Vanderpump knows and this is
kind of sort of some inside teeth if you
watch the third season of Real
Housewives when Adrienne Maloof did not
show up for that reunion Andy Cohen says
if any housewife does not show for a
reunion they are fired
so Lisa Vanderpump knows that she has to
show for their reunion and a reunion is
a 14 hour
battle royale mm-hmm like it is like a
cage match in heels yeah so you have to
be prepared and I think for that she
won't she's been able to avoid all the
girls for the last few months but she
won't be able to avoid them either
unless she doesn't go to the reunion
because she doesn't want to be on the
show anymore because the craft has run
its course that's impossible no one's
gonna give up that much money in that
much publicity this show works as an
advertising platform for her brands that
she has built and that are beautifully
woven that are still being built on Tom
and
then from garden in Vegas yeah yeah so
she needs the show as much as the show
needs her and I will say this I do think
that it's caught up to her but I also
think the show needs her and I also
think that all she has to do is approach
us yeah you know what Doreen I was mad
at you I was shady and I'm sorry I'm
sorry that I was hurt so badly that I
felt the need to do this to all she's
and it's over it's all she physically
cannot apologize and I think for her she
digs herself into these deeper and
deeper and deeper holes because no one
in her camp or in her posse will say
yeah just gotta apologize I mean you
overreacted
you went too far you were upset that
that dog ended up at a shelter but she
got too far into the game and she just
kept on making up not making up things
she kept on spinning them yeah and she
kept on digging even deeper when she
could have in an bahamas admitted to her
part in it it would've been done he
wouldn't even still be talking about it
because it's really not even such a big
thing but it seems like tonight's
episode she's putting it out in the
press now and I remember when we read
the story and we were reporting it on
the show and we were like this is
bananas wait did you die at how the
season started yes oh my god dramatic
did you die yeah we didn't see the whole
fight no you she's only like a branch of
it right and when Ken gets involved it's
getting nasty it's getting nasty you
know what though I think this is a great
season of housewives
it's one of personally one of the best
ones I've seen in a very long time like
I always think the show is good there's
been a lot of great seasons this is one
of those great seasons yeah and that the
pages keep on folding and unfolding and
unfolding you have to watch them in oh
of course I'll watch even if it's bad
cuz I just like love Erica I'm loving to
reat right now and like Kyle is always
just like I think everybody on the show
including I know a lot of people don't
like Denise Richards Denise Richards is
interview bites are hilarious they're
hilarious I've been the jury is out for
me on her you're making me like her a
little bit more just because she wasn't
what I expected and I don't care about
Charlie Sheen so it's like when
everything relates back to Charlie I
inevitably I'm not gonna care but I
think I think there's a lot of promise
for her you know it was like that Eileen
Davidson of it all where it's like her
first season I was like what is she
doing on the show and now I miss her
every miss her every day
and the problem is you want Denise
Richards to be more glamorous yes
well because in Beverly all of these
women are so glamorous like delete when
she showed up at LDP's house like in
that Dolce dress I was like hungry she
was starving she was starving starving
oh my god they just they bring it I
guess I love the level of dedication
that they all have even those who aren't
Teddy who's not so hair-and-makeup
centric she's bringing it you know
there's more it's like they really take
this job seriously and they want to give
us the best show 100% but they know like
once it's out there it's out there for
life you don't want to be stuck in the
mean because the Queen's will make a
meme about your ass by anything honey
they will turn your ass into Jeff in two
seconds you don't want to be stuck in
that jiff that's going to every gay man
in America without a hair makeup our
lash on no like you don't want to be
that [ __ ] that's why at Lisa Rinna
always she knows everything she doesn't
even talk about Rinna once Rinna is an
enigma wrapped in a riddle and cash
in cash but Lisa how many opening lines
I would love for everybody to Google
Lisa Rinna's IMDB and get that resume
Lisa Rinna has been working in this
business for four decades non-stop she
is the hustler of the century and I love
that right now and through housewives
she's at the top of her game
you know I need new breath has been
released through Rena right she's
killing it love it well you're killing
it I must let you go cuz you're a busy
man thank you so much for being here
where can everyone follow you it's like
the epilady sitter at the lady sitter on
instagram and on twitter and you can
watch just a sip on the e-news youtube
website it's so good and daily pop 12:11
central on e you'll be back tomorrow
yes and Claudia will be joining you on
Friday so they show usually ends around
noon we'll all be running home to watch
daily pop I'm so excited thank you so
much for being thank you so much fun are
the best time everything that you do I'm
like your biggest fan so I'm
I was able to keep my cool Thank You
Jackie like just thank you for all the
work that you do and for telling us to
Google it oh my god Google it girl
google it
Bible T tomorrow
you